now what I'm going to do instead is I'm
actually going to return back to this
one going to return to this line now we
can talk out a factor of Seck theta in
both cases but I've learned to actually
rewrite it and show you there's
something else we can do here by taking
advantage of partial fractions now
you're like what partial fractions where
are the partial fractions in here well I
agree it's not obvious yet so let me try
and show you SEC squared on sec right I
can write that degree they're both
reciprocal i can write that as cause on
car swim figured that said okay now the
reason why this is useful to me is
because this guy here i can actually it
seems counter to you but i can actually
break this apart remember how when you
get to something nice and simple when
you were a trig identity right sometimes
a tree guy then it has to get worse
before it gets better right and that's
exactly what I'm doing you this is as
simple as it gets but if you don't
understand the fall for it you're stuck
so I'm going to try and make it a little
bit Messier and see if the parts if
there's more of them will be easier to
deal with okay so i'm going to write
this as cars on 1 minus signs web you
see how it's ordered going in Reverse
see this is that this is the opposite of
what i usually do okay now how look at
that guy can we deal with this just as
it integrals imagine if that was your
first the first line of the question
that was the only thing you got come on
think think think what tools can you use
yeah right now yeah okay so i can say i
can say if I let now I can do either of
them in this case I'm going to go for
just say better the reason why I'm going
for sine theta is because this is the
derivative of sine theta you see it okay
that's going to be super useful to me so
I'm going to say from that line I'm
going to say let u equal sign thena
right so therefore do you on the theater
is equal to Y is thinner
and that's really good because I have a
cos theta right it's right there on the
numerator so I don't need to muck about
with this tech reciprocals or anything
like that I'm just going to go ahead and
make my substitution right this is the
integral on that's d you on d think on
that numerator there i'm replacing the
cause they'd up and then i've got 1
minus u square d theta which probably
cancers yeah okay now you remember I
said partial fraction and you're like
what what partial fractions their
partial projects that's why we had to do
that this Maurice I remaining in fact
this is a very very easy case of partial
fractions once you do the factorization
you see okay this is what I'm going to
break this up into okay so can we just
quickly do this together I'm going to
say this is equal to this
yep I'm going to combine the fractions
just like we did this morning this is a
really really nice easy case and now
that I have got a common denominator I
can cancel cancel and that lets me
actually substitute some things in i'll
give you a bit of a shortcut if you let
u equal 1 u equal 1 then this guy
disappears right so you've got a times
too so that's going to sign this is
going to be a half right if you let a
equal negative 1 then this guy is going
to disappear and in fact you get the
same thing right do you see that you get
B times 2 1 minus negative 1 so b is
also equal to a half so if this is a
half and this is a half then i can write
this as two fractions now ok ready I've
got i'm going to write the half on the
top because i'm not to factorize it out
thank you ok what do you think it's just
something I can work with it is right
this is so much better actually making
some progress now ok I'm going to take
that factor of a half at the front and
just be careful she must be careful this
is a log but it's also chain rule with a
log right because the derivative the
inside function is negative 1 so this is
actually negative log off and we're
going to go absolute value of 1 minus u
ok what about this guy what is he the
code plus log off I'll see you yep
unless you classical is it something
okay this is great I'm getting somewhere
right I've got the the composition of
two logs what could I do with this I can
put them together and combine them so I
still just enough space here remember
that it's this one minus this one just
watch out for your sides okay so this is
actually our half log absolute value
this is on the numerator and this is on
the Nugget of them ok ok now we've gone
very very far away from home ok but we
can climb back we can climb back right I
noticed two things I know there's two
things number one I can get you out of
here by going back there no I mitsui
this half that just kind of appeared
right he appeared out of the partial
fractions okay this half actually
relates this log doesn't it I could use
a log real key to not have to write a
half I could write instead the square
root that's a power of a half their
rights i'm going to do both of those in
one here this is log of the square root
of what's underneath here 1 plus sine
theta one minus sine people and then
this constant
okay so brilliant this is we're almost
there okay um we look at this right and
it's kind of like hmm what can I do with
this okay now when you have a look back
at where we came from we came from all
these squared things right we came from
all these squared things and what I've
got over here I'm kind of missing
squared things ok so I'm going to
reintroduce them so that i can because
i've gotta like we did with the
integration inception right i'm going to
climb back out of this feeder level okay
and so I'm going to have to introduce
the squares in there to do that okay so
here's how about we go i'm going to say
log of the square root of now what shall
i do what how can i modify this
algebraic this tree measured fraction in
order to introduce my squares and also
cares or something out what kind of yeah
okay if i multiply by 1 plus sine theta
on the numerator i'm going to get this
agree on the denominator i'm going to
get one minus sine square 1 minus sine
squared that is a really really good
sign okay because of course 1 minus sine
squared is cos square but all the
denominator it's actually sec squared
that's very very promising okay you see
so therefore what I've got real tired
constant okay what i've really got here
is log of the square root of 1 plus sign
feed on all squared on cons squared
let's cross them now this is even better
if his even better because look I have a
square root and I have a couple of
things that are square so therefore i
can just take the square root of both of
you this is really log of 1 plus sine
theta on constantly did you see I'm just
taking the square root of those things
I'm almost there I'm so very close okay
what am I gonna do you
I'm trying to get out of theaters right
the thing I can use to get out of
theaters has to be tan theta I is there
a tear theatre in while I'm just really
yeah there is he's right there ok so I'm
going to split apart this numerator one
little ice theater is of course sakdina
and then side theater on cos theta is
the 10 but I was after now just going to
pause there that there that is a form
that people have have learned for this
right that's what we actually did all
the way through and they original people
use partial fractions to get from there
just like we did to get to hear ok but
you'll see sometimes a textbook like the
crew nice ones sometimes the blue black
and white and blue one that I gave you
it's a here's a result on the syllabus
but now you see where it came from ok
not quite finished I know what 10 peter
is 10 feet up it looks to me is X on a
but I can use that to work out what sect
leader is right because if I'm in a
triangle here which i can because of
restriction that I was noticing before
this is a point what now that I need
this I actually do have to escape from
north to punch you but that's ok ok
because sin x squared did you notice
that that's fine so if this this theta
there there's a right angle this is
opposite over adjacent so tell me what
the Merseyside is huh a squared plus x
squared do you say the square root of a
squared plus x squared ok so therefore
therefore what have I got here this is
in fact log of all right the SEC theta
is instead of adjacent over hypotenuse
which is cause its hypotenuse on
adjacent all right yep plus what Stan
theatre you excellent ok now at this
point your heart should sort of skip a
beat cuz you're like wait no this is not
right I wasn't suppose
and there I was supposed to end I
dropped it off the board I'll just sit
in there without these a's in here no I
just spent two white board and are you
serious I've gotta roll no I don't got
it exactly right what's missing I'm not
finished here not finished yeah I'm egg
how long okay so just to make it clear
what on earth arisaka I've got two
fractions with a common denominator so
I'm going to right now as one fraction
with the columnar roof but of course
because of my log rules that I used here
right yeah I'm going to separate them up
this is just this is log of the thing
that I want which is this right it's
that guy this is on the denominator
right so in fact it's minus log a which
is in constant plus another constant so
these guys I'm just going to call them a
different constant ok still constant and
so thank goodness i have this spot left
on my boy I'm done